[Music]
i was scrolling back in time
recently past the billions of little
moments
i've lived all these photos that i've
captured over the years
and i stumbled upon a region of my photo
bank that i
hadn't really ever looked at before it
was like right here
we had just gotten married and we walked
from our little apartment
up to the mountain near our house how
you doing
we had no idea if we could actually get
to the top or how long it would take
but we hiked we camped at the top
and we watched the sun fall over the
mountain
and i just love looking at these photos
[Music]
a few weeks later iz surprised me with a
road trip to san diego and then into
tijuana
crossing the border to tijuana i had
completely forgotten
about this experience we spent so many
hours on the beach playing frisbee we
ate tacos we visited
old friends there was this political
rally that we wandered into
man i just i i don't
even remember that and then suddenly i
do
that was quote one of the happiest days
of my life
okay
when i look at these photos at these
videos
something happens in my brain
it's like i'm mourning something and
yet celebrating it too i've been
thinking about this feeling for a while
and i've been talking to my friend
nathaniel drew who also
is very interested in investigating this
so hold on do you wanna i feel like i'm
overthinking this but i want you to be
happy with the framing that i've got
at least frame rate i'm shooting in 24.
that's video
dude we can't help ourselves talk about
composition and frame rate
right up top but yeah no we're
my theory on nostalgia is that
nostalgia is kind of like fire okay and
it can be kind of like playing fire so
fire can it can warm you up but
i feel like you can get lost in it too
staring too long at the fire getting too
close you can get burned
as we talked we sort of laid out our
theories of
what's going on here and then we decided
how we could investigate this further by
experimenting on ourselves
what would happen to my brain if i
started listening to
music from 2005
and watching old home videos
and smelling old smells and
just sparking that feeling every day
if i may just make a guess here i do
wonder if this will lead to
you kind of returning to your roots
whatever that means so
nathaniel and i set out on separate
journeys both of us trying to spark
a certain type of nostalgia in our own
way
nathaniel's goal was to go back in time
and start to experience the world in a
more analog
way without social media and phones and
etc and for me
the journey was going to be getting out
old journals
old books old smells old music
and cultivating a practice for every day
i expose myself
to this old stuff and see what that does
to my brain
i dived into the neuroscience and looked
at the studies that have been done on
what happens to the brain
but i also looked at my own personal
experience and i learned a lot
and that's what i want to share with you
today
so i have a theory on how all of us
experience
life it looks like this
okay so you were born here my theory is
that as you grow up you start
experiencing the world like this
this little ring represents the stuff
that you're thinking about
worrying about excited about this ring
stretches
maybe a few days back and forward in
time
maybe a week or two but not much more
than that
if you were living totally in the
present moment it would look something
like this
if you were constantly thinking about
everything everything that has happened
over the course of your entire year or
your life
the ring would look a lot more like this
but i believe most people's conscious
experience looks like this
thinking about the good and stressful
things that happened yesterday at work
or worrying about the good and stressful
things that are coming up tomorrow
or maybe next week we have a productive
day at work
and then you have a really good
conversation with your sister on the
phone one evening
and then you also get in a fight with
your partner
and i believe that most of us use the
information in this ring
to construct the current story of
ourselves
in other words we use this information
to decide what we think and
feel about ourselves who we think we are
but as we move forward these events will
fade and
new events will come into the ring and
help us construct a new story
of who we think we are what we feel
about ourselves
[Music]
so you're moving along and then one
night something really good happens
you go out with friends you dance you
have so much fun
it's the first week of october and the
air is turning cool and crisp
it smells like fall it smells like the
city it smells like liquor like perfume
like
freedom you have this one conversation
that is so
exciting so inspiring you feel connected
to this place to these people
and then it's over and for a few days
you consciously
remember that night you fondly think
about it but a week later
you kind of have no reason to think
about it anymore that night sort of
starts to fade
those conversations that feeling those
smells those memories are still stored
away
but your conscious mind has new stuff to
put its spotlight on
that night as a memory as an experience
gets filed away in some dusty file
cabinet somewhere in the depths of your
long-term memory
and then suddenly it's a time in your
life that looks
so different from that great night you
had with friends
you haven't seen friends in a long time
you're lonely you're wondering if you've
even ever had
friends you're wondering if you're even
likable
you're going off the information that's
available to you
the stuff that's in this ring which on
both sides
is full of dull quiet loneliness
but what if somehow you could retrieve
that knight from the old dusty file
cabinet in your long-term memory
you dust it off you maybe edit it a
little bit
so that it just includes the best parts
and then you bring it forth
and put it in the ring something happens
to your brain
when you do this
suddenly you have more information to
add to your story about yourself
this information is old information but
it feels
new because you haven't thought about it
in a really long time and it challenges
your current
story the story about you being lonely
and unlikable
and in this moment you feel two things
really strongly
you feel a literal physical warmness
a wonder a comfort a happiness and
belonging
but the other feeling you get is a
yearning to
be back in that moment and an
acknowledgement that it will never
happen again
these two feelings are the ingredients
for the potent
experience of nostalgia
[Music]
so when neuroscientists look at the
brain of people who are experiencing
nostalgia
they see something pretty interesting
they see these
two spots that fire at once and sort of
start talking to each other
a very unique process in the brain this
one
is the mind recalling the memory it's
technically called
chronological remoteness let's just call
it memory and this one
is your emotional network the stuff that
makes you
feel happy or sad and during nostalgia
specifically
it's firing in the reward centers the
good
the positive yes brain likes this
these two fire together and connect with
each other
it's a strange neural dance between
these two
unlikely partners of memory and
emotional reward
this feeling and reaction is more potent
if
one the memory has to do with belonging
or personal
attachment like friends and family or if
the feeling was a compelling
impactful moment in your life that had a
lot of personal meaning
maybe a big career thing or a big
life-changing moment
and number two the feeling is more
intense the longer it's been
since you thought about it so like that
feeling with me
on the beach in tijuana i literally had
not
thought about that in eight years and so
looking at those photos it was a
compelling
personal meaningful moment my brain was
going wild
the studies on this don't just look at
the fmris and the
brain and all of that stuff which is
really interesting
but it also looks at what actually
happens in the current day life of the
person who is experiencing nostalgia
what some of these studies are finding
is that nostalgia can actually
increase somebody's personal view of
themselves their self-esteem
and it can help combat the effects of
loneliness
as i cultivated nostalgia i really
started to understand why that is and
how that actually works
i am listening to weezer to an album
that came out when i was a senior in
high school
and it is just flooding my
world with this feeling
one of the things that keeps coming back
to me is the people
the people i was with like the the
friday nights
i would have with my friends the place
is there
in my memory but the people i was with
i feel like their presence in some
strange way
as i cultivate these memories it's
really weird
i like see their faces i like feel like
i'm with them
again it's like good and warm but it's
also
like hurtful like i found myself wanting
to turn this music off because i was
like oh i don't want to go there right
now
it's very it's very contradictory these
feelings
anyway back to it this is in keeping
with my broader theory about
the stories we tell ourselves and how
the information in our little ring
is usually the information we use to
construct our conscious story
and that introducing old memories that
are positive or meaningful
or tell a different story than your
current one can
really help you think differently about
who you are and what your life is
your conscious story becomes richer
and more flush with good experiences
and positive information about you and
your life
so while i was doing this nathaniel was
also doing it on his side
but in a very different way we're off to
a bad start here
where are we i have no idea we're here
actually
the last time i remember ever even
holding a map like this
was with my mom 15 years ago
okay but nostalgia has a dark side too
one of the big takeaways from the
studies on nostalgia
find that people actually lean on
nostalgia during hard times
they'll use it as sort of a coping
mechanism and this sometimes can be
exploited by marketers or in a lot of
cases
politicians during the old days when a
crime was a crime
we will make america great again
this happens in so many different
contexts to the far-right
nationalistic movements in japan that
are hearkening back to
the japanese empire and how much better
it was you can also look at
isis and their focus on hearkening back
to the glory days
of the old caliphate it happened here in
this country in 2016
with make america great again hearkening
back to some
ill-defined fake censored past that
never really existed
but that helps people who are maybe
struggling with
changing demographics in the country or
losing power
to feel like they have something to
latch on to these political campaigns
exploit that same brain process that
i experience when i look at old photos
but instead
they utilize it to mobilize supporters
[Music]
so i did this for a month i cultivated
nostalgia
every day listened to old music
and read journals and looked at old
photos and footage
and i can say that i definitely learned
a lot so during these strange
times of loneliness and non-social
interaction
remember that your ring is full of
information that
is not super indicative of who you
really are
if you're feeling lonely or disconnected
i recommend you experiment with taking
the edge off
with a dose of nostalgia
um i would probably want to meet
one of the guys like leonardo da vinci
that were really
smart and really good thanks for
watching everybody
this was quite the journey and
i have all these journals back here
maybe too much
there's such thing as over documenting
i've learned so before you go
i want to just tell you about skillshare
who sponsored today's video skillshare
is a place where you go to learn new
skills i'm a
giant fan of online learning i believe
you can open
so many creative doors if you dedicate
yourself
to taking online classes that's how i
learned all of my skills
and skillshare is a perfect place to do
that it is
incredibly cheap the first thousand
people to use the link in my description
will get a free trial of skillshare
premium this is a membership that allows
you to watch
everything on the skillshare website for
free from photography
to videography to design to animation
to entrepreneurial skills to cooking
there are so many options
what i love about skillshare is that you
pay one subscription
price and you get unlimited access to
all of the tutorials you can watch
dozens of tutorials
so go check that out there's a course on
there that was actually just made by our
friend nathaniel drew who
you saw in this video nathaniel does a
course on finding your voice as an
online creator
and it's a fantastic course he breaks
down everything he knows about
creating a personal authentic voice
as a creator on the internet nathaniel's
a very talented storyteller and
just a good teacher so go click the link
in the description when you do that it
supports this channel but
it also kickstarts a new chapter in your
life
of learning skills on the internet which
again
is a big value of mine so thank you all
for watching
and i hope you have a wonderful day
we'll see you soon